ou alors on met en grosses pièces chaque
jour christelle devant quelques 300
baguette et 150 croissante que son mari
jean christophe façonne et cuit à
l'intérieur de ce bull trucks
c'est à dire un camion toutes équipées
pour la boulangerie le couple a décidé
d'en acheter un pour vendre du pain en
zone rurale la complexité du milieu
rural c'est que tout ferme tous cas ce
label est il ya qu'une boulanger partout
et c'était une idée qui lui avait
traversé la tête depuis un moment mais
on n'avait pas le support et quand on a
découvert support on a pris contact avec
pascal qui est donc le créateur du ball
trap et on avait un le matériel donc on
se dit on n'est pas une envie de liberté
qui à quelques contraintes
le boulanger qui exerçait avant à la
bazoge des doit désormais s'adapter à
l'espace exigu passe d'un fourni de 200
m² 1 un fournil de deux mètres carrés
c'est autre chose à travailler
différemment on fait des gestes beaucoup
plus petit par contre ce qui est sympa
c'est le contact avec les clients qui
est différent de notre l'a28 fournil on
est plus sur une clientèle de marché on
discute avec les gens sont beaucoup plus
convivial ce qui change aussi c'est
qu'ils ne peuvent pas utiliser
l'appellation boulangerie car il ne
pétrissent pas le camp sur place mais
chez eux à une trentaine de kilomètres
ce détail ne freine pas les clients pour
qui ce camion sera bientôt le seul
endroit où trouver du pain frais ivy
combret il ya une boulangerie mais bon
et les personnes en partir en retraite
donc bon il nous faut et puis là s'est
bien fondu peu extrême c'est le pas à
d'autres fois je me rappelle quand
j'étais petit je mangeais dépeint comme
ça que l'époque qui était si bon c'est
tellement bon plus le secret de
jean-christophe il n'utilise que des
farines locales et travaille longtemps
la pâte
le couple vadrouille en ce moment entre
le village de proust des salons et des
marchés de noël mais il espère bientôt
rayonner dans d'autres villages autour
d'îles et combret